analizar esta épica carrera vamos a
hablar con tatiana rodríguez periodista
del diario 'as' colombia quien nos
acompaña desde la ciudad de bogotá está
tiene primero que todo gracias por estar
con nosotros cuál fue la clave de esta
emocionante victoria de verstappen hoy
que prácticamente no llegó a tener todo
perdido
hola buenas noches un honor estar con
ustedes acá bueno creo que hablando de
lo que pasó hoy en abu dhabi hubo tres
momentos que le dieron el título a max
verstappen el primero definitivamente
fue checo pérez el mexicano fue
fundamental para que el equipo tuviera
primero la confianza de sentir que podía
estar en igualdad de condiciones a
mercedes cuando estuvo en ese mano a
mano con luis y porque desde la
clasificación con la estrategia para
darle el rebufo a ver está pen y lo hizo
todo bien para que luego está pensé
ganar a la ´pole position´ lo segundo
claramente el accidente de latif y
normalmente lo que es mala suerte para
unos es bueno para otros y esta vez
significó nada menos que un título
mundial para macs verstappen y lo
tercero una vez más la estrategia de red
bull
primero hacer que max entrara tan pronto
salió el safety car poner las ruedas
blandas y presionar para que la fia no
dejará de dejar adelantar o lo dejara
más bien adelantar a él a los rezagados
fue completamente definitivo para el
título
largo con ruedas blandas termino con
ruedas blandas y siempre haciendo algo
diferente al rival que es como la regla
o que fue como la regla de chris horner
durante toda la temporada para red bull
mercedes que no quiso entrar a boxes
cuando salió les explicaré quizás está
empezando sobre esa decisión hablando
sobre esa polémica sobre esa decisión de
la fiesta tiene crees que hubo demasiado
protagonismo de la fia en este mundial
con sus decisiones
para mí si juan no solamente en abu
dhabi ni en las tres últimas carreras
que vimos en los emiratos árabes sino
durante todo el campeonato mundial un
campeonato histórico un campeonato
emocionante se oyó un poquito empañado
con las actuaciones de michael machine
que es el director de carrera de la
fórmula uno para la fia que realmente
tomó decisiones un poco polémicas
durante todo el año nada más por nombrar
algunas la suspensión del gran premio de
bélgica la sanción de 10 segundos que le
dio a hamilton luego de provocar el
accidente de máx verstappen en
silverstone subsiguiente a su triunfo en
el territorio británico en brásil creo
que fue la mayor vergüenza cuando max
tocó el alerón de hamilton y hamilton
salió con una pieza indebida se
demoraron casi 24 horas para dar un
veredicto y bueno lo de arabia lo de abu
dhabi que seguramente claramente cerró
con dudas y polémicas lo que está
haciendo la fia en la fórmula1 cómo se
está manejando el reglamento y cómo se
está aplicando también en las diferentes
circunstancias que se presentan en las
carreras
al margen de esta polémica estamos de
acuerdo en que ha sido un mundial de
fórmula1 muy emocionante que supone para
la fórmula1 haber tenido después de
tantos años un mundial tan emocionante
como este
supone mucho juanes un gran avance para
que la afición siga creciendo en todas
partes del mundo especialmente en
latinoamérica también y miren este día
final del campeonato muchos deportes se
unieron en torno a la fórmula1 tanto el
fútbol el ciclismo el baloncesto otros
deportes se unieron para ver la
definición ya sea que fueran por más ya
sea que fueran por louis pero esto es
algo que
engrandece mucho el deporte y le sirve
mucho al deporte
hace muchísimos años 47 años que no
teníamos una definición con dos
corredores que llegaban empatados a la
última carrera expertos que han visto la
fórmula1 desde hace muchísimos años
confirman y coinciden en decir que
probablemente es uno de los mundiales
más emotivos que hemos tenido en los
últimos 30 años y nos tocó a verlo a
nosotros nos tocó verlo a nosotros somos
muy suertudos de poder verlo y esto es
muy bueno para el deporte
además con todo lo que pasó se terminó
el dominio de un piloto llegó otro para
ocupar ese trono para tomar ese trono
hemos vivido también durante todo el año
el renacer de ferrari el renacer de
manglar la despedida de raikkonen
ya estamos esperando la la nueva
temporada de directo survive entonces
creo que ha sido algo muy refrescante
para la fórmula 1